[Music]
let's go to william in fort worth tejas
what's up william
hey guys how are y'all we're good
brother what's up
so
my
i
i just uh last friday i saw a week ago
um actually
um quit my job because my wife requested
me too
and
we were having we're having this
discussion now of well what do we do
with our finances because
it seems like you should have had that
conversation before she told you to quit
why why did she tell you to quit your
job
i have
i have a real bad heart and i was
working in the heat and it was
getting to the point where i was passing
out at work
okay so she was right so her impulse was
let's a go with don't die b let's figure
out money right
yes okay
[Laughter]
rachel is a wife she's like i'm gonna go
with that one okay so
hold on why did your wife have to save
your life
why didn't you come to this
determination on your own
because i'm one that won't stop if i'm
unless i'm told no
like
i i will
i'll go until i
burn out
can we die
can we just uh
it's immature can we can we decide we're
going to be different from this point
forward
yes okay good so we got a wake-up call
so what's your question
how do i talk to my wife about our
finances because we have two accounts
she has her account i have my account
okay
none of them are tied together
and
so
i
i mean i don't see what she's spending i
don't she doesn't see what i spend and
i've talked to her about it
previously and she's like well i don't
want you to be mad at me for what i what
i spend
but we're in this together for sure for
sure um
which is kind of a common thing that i
hear when couples don't have their money
together it's like well i don't want you
to see because i don't want i don't want
to get ragged on of like i go to target
and probably spend too much money and i
want you to see it and you know like
that that is a
normal discussion point that we hear
from people when their accounts are
separate you're talking about combining
them so
i'm not saying that's right but that
that is a common phrase that we hear so
would she be correct would you get mad
at how she spends her money you think
no
i wonder why she thinks that you will
she's a school teacher and
she she told me right before i
um
the thursday before i i put my
my
resignation in
that
well this next check is the one i play
with
i said well what do you do with it she
said
well i don't pay any bills with it i
said okay so
yeah you have enough yeah i mean i mean
you've got to pay all your all your
bills with one check
and you play with it yeah and there's
there's so there's so much here william
that he's like can i tell you what i
think william i think she's
i think she acts more like your mom than
your wife
and yeah i think that she has had to
create a world where she makes sure that
she can eat and everybody there's a roof
and there's bills that are paid
because you're a guy that's just going
to put his head down and do whatever
he's going to do even if it's going to
kill him
is that fair
yeah and then finally she said hey how
about you don't die like you're getting
pretty close to the edge here
and this conversation sounds like it
starts with you coming home and saying
i've been really mature and i've been
thinking about me to the point that i'm
just gonna work myself to death because
that's kind of what i think i'm worth
and she looked at you finally as you
were heading off the edge and said hey i
think you're worth a little bit more
than that because you're my husband
and so
i want to enter into a world where we're
going to do this together and i've quit
my job i've said i i tapped out right
there's no bravado
in the jujitsu world there's an old
thing like you don't tap out you just no
true jiu-jitsu artists tap out when they
get caught right that's it's so you can
live to go another day and that's what
you've done here and
you can
stand before your wife actually take a
knee before your wife and say i've been
immature the way i've lived and we're
going to have to start this whole thing
over build something new
i want to start by being all in together
on this deal and i'm not going to judge
your purchases i'm i'm going to choose
to go first too will you do this with me
yeah and william i mean honestly from
what even john what you just said which
i think was so spot on of her having to
create this world
you know
within herself and her money
uh
with
with you and your decisions all that
right like you all have just been
playing in all these separate um these
separate fields and so my prayer would
be that she longs
to do this with you that she longs for
unity not just in your money but in your
marriage and into other decisions in
life not just about money and so
honestly if i were your wife if my if i
was in that situation and my husband
came home
and apologized
and said i'm so sorry that this is how
we've been doing our life and i take and
i take responsibility for not engaging
you
when it comes to money making you feel
like you have to
um
keep stuff from me and
and and i don't want that anymore i want
our marriage to be
i want us to to be fully known to be
open and to know what is going on
because we're we're a team in this like
and in this life do you all have kids
no okay
and so if that you know becomes part of
the formula later in life for you guys
it's like you want you want your
marriage to be
to be so unified and that you know each
other so well
um that it just brings this level of joy
william that i think you guys have been
missing and again the money stuff is a
symptom of a lot more going on but i
think if you went to her and said i'm so
sorry i'm so sorry for how i've acted
i'm so sorry for x y and z and i want to
sit me and you together and agree
and agree on our money and work together
as a team i want to do this together
and
and you guys and tactically sitting
there and listing out a budget like hey
if you're wanting to spend money let's
look at where we're at let's
and i want to spend money so how do we
do this you know do we each have our
personal line items in the budget uh
have money goals if you guys have debt
to say hey let's work to start paying
this off together like i want you guys
to start working in unison but i think
william a huge step a huge step
would be for you to go in and apologize
hey william
why do you think you're worth
nothing
i don't know um
i have a college degree but
i can't use it
it's i mean it's in business
administration i don't even know what
what your degree is yeah you're busy i
disagree with this statement you could
you've decided not to
and that's that's fine it's all well and
good
but there's something beneath this that
you think man i'm just worth putting my
head down and just going until until
this thing runs out of gas and it took a
woman who loves you to say no no no i
need you
here's the deal william i'd really love
you to be able to look in the mirror and
say i'm worth being here
and i'm worth having a life full of joy
and i'm worth having a marriage full of
joy and and hold on the line austin will
pick ups and i want to give you guys a
year's subscription of ramsay plus for
you guys to do every dollar together and
to go through the videos of financial
peace university together and you guys
start over start translate to starting
today